please in Oregon this morning they are
trying to identify a group of vandals
that destroyed an iconic Natural
Landmark a tourist captured the video
people pushing over rock formation
happened at the Cape Kawana State
Natural Area that southwest of Portland
Ben Tracy shows us why whoever did this
could pay a big price a rock formation
standing for thousands of years gone in
mere moments a seven-second video posted
online shows three people toppling a
popular sandstone pedestal at Oregon's
Cape go Wanda State Park the cell phone
video was shot by David calles I'm like
you know they're not gonna push down I
don't know how much the rock weighs but
you know this huge rock and then you see
in my footage you know that they just
toppled the rock over the iconic piece
of sandstone was known locally as the
duckbill it was about seven feet tall
and seven to ten feet wide on top though
fenced off it's long been a destination
for nature lovers and nature
photographers it just made me upset cuz
everybody knows that rock and it's just
like breaks my heart because you know so
many people have grown up or on that
rock state officials first thought it
had collapsed due to erosion late last
week if there are crimes here that will
be up to the state police to decide what
they are and how to pursue them we go it
vandalism in state parks is not new
two men were given probation in order to
pay fines and restitution totaling more
than two thousand dollars for destroying
this Utah rock formation in 2013 and
actress Vanessa Hudgens was fined $1,000
for carving into a red rock wall in
Arizona the Oregon sand stone pedestal
stood in a dangerous part of the 185
acre nature area at least six people
including three teenagers fell to their
deaths off the cliffs including two
drownings in the past two years our
first concern is that making sure people
are safe and then second what do we need
to do to be clearer with people about
what's appropriate behavior in a park
the photographer confronted the Vandals
who claimed the formation was a safety
hazard but he doesn't buy it for them to
have the intentions of just knocking
over the rock for the
a purpose of being vandals just you know
just makes me upset for CBS this morning
Ben Tracy Los Angeles